les dernières images diffusées par
moscou ne veulent laisser aucun doute
aucun répit sur la ligne de fond
six mois après le début de la guerre
des combats de haute intensité
des bombardements continus de parts et
d'autres
mais aujourd'hui les positions semblent
presque figée quand on regarde cette
carte les rues sont contigus 82 mille
kilomètres carrés depuis mars environ
deux fois la suisse mais désormais il
stagne à peine quelques centaines de km²
gagné depuis le début de l'été dans les
tranchées ce soldat ukrainien résume
bien l'état d'esprit général
le moral est plus élevé qu'aux premiers
jours de la guerre quand on perdait sans
cesse du terrain contre les russes mais
il est moins haut que quand tout le
monde s'attendait à ce que les
forceraient s'effondre maintenant on est
quelque part au milieu
les russes ne parviennent pas pour
l'instant à leur objectif affiché
s'emparer de l'intégralité du dombass à
l'est il quand d'épuiser l'ennemi avec
des tirs d'artillerie nourris le long de
la ligne de front et essaye d'avancer
sur bach mouthe
les troupes de moscou ont subi de
lourdes pertes quatre-vingt mille
soldats morts ou blessés selon les
services américains
5240 véhicules détruits ou immobilisé et
il n'aurait plus la capacité de survoler
l'espace aérien ukrainien il opte pour
une stratégie de russification des
territoires conquis distribution de
passeports
et cérémonies patriotiques
comme ici à mario paul
guerre de positions côté russe
trappe tactique côté ukrainien
les forces ukrainiennes ont réussi à
reprendre quelques kilomètres près dix y
sommes et en banlieue de carson mais
surtout elle multiplie les bombardements
ennemis et semble préparer une contre
offensive
elle cible des ponts des dépôts de
munition est jusqu'à l'état major de la
flotte russe en crimée une première
malgré de lourdes pertes quasi
équivalentes à celles des russes l'armée
ukrainienne semble plus forte qu'il ya
trois mois grâce au soutien
international et aux armes de pointe
livré par l'occident on voit que les
ukrainiens ont petit à petit et galets
l'armée russe qui fait qu'elles
n'arrivent plus réellement avancer donc
la possibilité qu'on reste sur un front
qui seraient gelés comme ce qu'on a subi
de 2014 à 2021 finalement ce serait une
option qui serait satisfaisante pour
aucune des deux parties mais aujourd'hui
en tout cas on est en train de
s'orienter vers ça pour donner
l'avantagé à kiev l'europe envisage des
missions de formation des soldats
ukrainien ils étaient unis eux
promettent 775 millions de dollars dette
supplémentaire